I see that all the time.
I have never found that
to be useful advice.
Forget the first hundred words.
You can't treat random people as tutors.
Today, I want to talk about 25
tips to learn a foreign language.
This is based on a blog
post written by Mark Manson.
Someone pointed out that this
was a, an interesting collection
of tips for language learning.
So I thought it would be interesting
to go through these 25 tips.
And give you my take on these tips,
how relevant, how useful they are.
Bear in mind that language
learning is very personal.
So what I like or dislike may not be
the same as what you like or dislike
or what Mark Manson likes or dislike.
His first tip is conversation,
conversation, conversation.
Now he was, I think, living in Buenos
Aires and faced with the difficulty
of communicating with locals.
So in that situation, if you're in a
country where the language is spoken
and you need to learn that language,
of course, you take advantage of
every opportunity to use the language.
However, as a strategy for
learning the language, I have
never considered conversation,
at least in the initial stages.
to be the key because you can't have
a conversation if you don't understand
what the other person is saying.
So I am much more inclined to prefer heavy
input based approach to language learning
and wait until you have a high enough
level of comprehension to where you can
have adult conversations with people.
And at that point, yes,
you do need to speak a lot.
The second thing he says is intensity
of study trumps length of study.
Well, intensity, yes.
And I do remember when I was learning
Mandarin Chinese, I had three hours a
day, one on one with the teacher, and
then I would spend five or six or seven
hours on my own listening and reading
and writing and learning characters.
And I learned in one year faster than
other diplomatic students, as with
the Canadian government in Hong Kong.
Uh, who took two years
and learned less well.
So I, I remember I came to the conclusion
at that time that creating that white heat
in your brain that comes from intensity
is very helpful, but we continue to learn.
So even after a period
of very intense learning.
It continues to gestate in your brain.
And there are other opportunities to use
the language and you are always improving
over a long, long period of time.
Number three, he says classes suck and
are an inefficient use of time and money.
One on one as the way I had it
in Hong Kong with a teacher,
a new teacher every hour.
Forcing me to say
something in the language.
I think that was very good, very intense.
However, sitting in a classroom
with 10 people, with a teacher,
especially if you have to travel a
half hour or 45 minutes to get to
the class, the classes are expensive.
In my case, the government was paying.
If I had to pay for that myself,
I wouldn't do it because we
can achieve so much on our own.
Listening and reading, and
then eventually finding an
opportunity to use the language.
Number four, know your motivation
for learning a new language.
That's important.
I was listening to a podcast, How
Stuff Works or something, to Americans.
And they were saying, why
would you learn a language?
Is it just for showing off?
No, that's, I don't think why
most people learn languages,
but it may be the case for some.
So you have to look at yourself.
Am I learning this language to show off?
Am I learning to communicate
with my grandmother?
Am I learning it because
I need it for work?
Am I learning it because I'm
interested in the culture?
It's important to understand why you're
doing it, because there are a lot of
moments during the process where you are
discouraged because you don't think you're
getting anywhere and you have to go back
to like, why am I actually doing it?
So that's a good point.
Number five, he says set learning goals.
Well, I've said that in a general sense,
my goal always is B2 on the European
Common Framework of Reference, which
is kind of fluent with mistakes and
places where you don't understand.
That to me is the goal.
Once you're there, you can continue.
To improve, but I very
often don't achieve that.
I move off a language where I'm
still at A2 and I go to another
language because I'm interested in it.
So to me, at my stage, the
goals aren't that important.
When I was a Canadian government language
student in Hong Kong, learning Mandarin
Chinese, I had a very specific goal.
I had to write the British
foreign service exam.
And I said, I want to
do that within a year.
So that was a very specific
goal for a specific purpose.
That's not the situation now.
And the goal will dictate what you do.
Are you going to spend
a lot of time writing?
Are you going to maintain a diary?
All the different things that you
can do, many of which are hard work.
If your goal is high enough, you will
have the discipline to do these things.
If you're more of a dilettante
like me, you'll be more of a
lazy language learner like I am.
Next thing he says, start with the most
common words, the 100 most common words.
I see that all the time.
I have never found that
to be useful advice.
If you are doing a lot of listening
and reading or even speaking, you
will encounter the most common 100
words, 500 words very, very often.
However, the frequency declines very
quickly and the major challenge...
Thereafter is going to be acquiring
the less frequent words, but the
most common words they look after
themselves, you needn't worry about it.
And if your goal is to learn the most
common hundred words so that you can
go and start talking to someone, you
will find, I think, in many, most
cases that you won't be able to follow
the conversation anyway, because
the person you're speaking to is not
going to limit what they have to say
to the hundred most common words.
Number seven, he says,
carry a pocket dictionary.
I never carry a pocket dictionary.
But dictionaries are very inefficient.
It takes time to find a word.
You forget what the meaning was as
soon as you close the dictionary,
I just find, you know, you end
up saying, how do you say this?
How do you say that?
Could you please repeat?
And you kind of struggle
through if you have that kind
of a rudimentary conversation.
I prefer to prepare myself through
lots of listening and reading
and then hope for the best.
So I don't carry a pocket dictionary.
Number eight, keep practicing
the new language in your head.
Again, I never...
Do that, not deliberately.
Now it may be that subconsciously I
have these phrases bouncing around in
my head, but I don't deliberately try
to practice the new language in my head.
I just don't do that.
That's not to say it's
not a good thing to do.
It's just not something
that I can, you know, do.
You're going to say a
lot of stupid things.
I accept it.
Yeah, I'm not sure it's stupid, but.
Uh, we are comfortable
in our own language.
Typically we feel we are, if we're
adults, we think we're adult.
We think we're intelligent.
We think we can express ourselves.
And all of a sudden in a new
language, we can't, we make mistakes.
We can't find the words
in a way it's unpleasant.
Although there is this sort of
compensating sense of achievement
when in fact, you are able to say
something, you are able to understand,
you get this tremendous power.
But yeah, there are certainly periods of
uncertainty and you have to accept that.
Number 10, he says, figure
out pronunciation patterns.
And he makes reference to Slavic
languages and Romance languages,
which have certain patterns.
I would rather hear say, when it comes
to pronunciation, focus on intonation.
If you can get the intonation of a
language, the rhythm of the language.
Then the pronunciation is
going to improve, your correct
usage is going to improve.
You should, you know, listen to that
intonation and try to imitate it.
Number 11, he says, use audio
and online courses for the first
hundred words and basic grammar.
Well, I've covered the
first hundred words.
I don't think that's important.
They'll come at you anyway.
Basic grammar, again, it's hard
to nail down the basic grammar.
You'll be struggling with basic
grammar for a long, long time.
He mentions various apps.
He doesn't mention LingQ, unfortunately.
Fine, yeah, there's all kinds of apps
and tools and resources online that
are going to help you, but the focus
should be on acquiring the language,
not necessarily just the first hundred
words, not necessarily the basic grammar.
Both of those things are going to
continue to elude you for quite a while.
Number twelve, he says, after
the first hundred words, focus
on becoming conversational.
Again, I don't know what that means.
You are not going to be
conversational with a hundred words.
Forget the first hundred
words, even forget trying to be
conversational at an early stage.
Focus on improving your comprehension,
acquiring vocabulary, speak
when you have the opportunity.
You're not going to be comfortably
conversational until you have a sufficient
vocabulary and a sufficient level.
Of comprehension, he's just
aiming for the brain melt.
Sure.
I think I understand what he's saying.
Go at it as intensively as you can, and
you will be engaging with the language.
It's kind of occupying
your every waking moment.
And interestingly, whatever you've
done before going to bed or during the
day, during the sleeping hours, that
is being reinforced and put into your.
Long term memory.
So the more intense that experience,
the bigger the brain melt, I guess, the
faster you're socking it into your brain.
Use a new language daily only
in the sense that listening and
reading are also using the language.
It's simply not practical
to be speaking daily.
But you should try to maintain some
consistency of engaging with the language.
And so that's certainly good advice.
Number 15.
How do you say X is the most important
sentence you can possibly learn?
Again, I don't agree with that.
How do you say X is not difficult to say?
You will learn that early,
but it's not a major help.
I think you'll find yourself
saying, I beg your pardon, could
you repeat that more often?
Because when we speak, we tend
to limit ourselves to what we can
say and the words that we have.
Number 16, he says, one on one tutoring is
the best and most efficient use of time.
It's the best and most efficient type of
tutoring or classroom learning one on one.
I don't believe in sitting with a group
of five or six or ten and taking turns.
Conversing, some are better than
others, not an efficient use of time,
but I think that listening, reading, or
dare I say using LingQ can be at least
as efficient a use of time as one on
one tutoring, but you need a mixture.
You need them all.
The tutor is stimulating, it's feedback.
It's, it's all good.
Number 17, date someone who
speaks the target language
and not your native language.
Uh, I'm married, so it doesn't apply.
You're selectively, you
know, removing anyone who.
Speaks English, if your native
language is English, harder to find.
I'm not sure how relevant
that is as a activity.
18.
If you can't find someone
cute who will put up with you,
find a language buddy online.
So with a language buddy is again, I
have to spend time teaching that person,
my language, English, so that's an hour
for every hour I get of speaking to them
in my target language, I would rather
spend more time with input activities.
And then pay 10, 15, 20 an hour
for an online tutor when I want.
Facebook chat plus Google
Translate equals winning.
Again, I'm not on Facebook.
I don't have any interest in Facebook.
Uh, Google Translate is useful
for written communication.
I think it's a little cumbersome.
Number 20, when you learn a new word,
try to use it a few times right away.
Again, a big part of language learning
to me is that it'd be natural.
I acquire so many words
through listening and reading.
I can't possibly use them all right away.
There's no opportunity to use them.
There's a gradual process where words
that we have seen and we're starting
to become familiar with eventually
become passive vocabulary and
eventually become active vocabulary.
I don't think you can short
circuit the The process by
trying to use them right away.
And if you do, you'll only slow down
your acquisition of a richer and
richer passive vocabulary, which is a
base that you need for comprehension.
And it's the base upon which all
other language skills are built.
So no, don't try to use it right away.
21, he says, TV shows, movies,
newspapers, magazines are good
supplements, but he says ultimately
nothing compares to the benefits of.
Speaking like conversations again, I
don't agree with that because if you're
into TV shows, movies, newspapers, and
magazines, you're expanding your horizons,
getting used to that new language
and everything associated with it.
If you limit yourself to what you can say,
it becomes a much more limited experience.
And I don't think that's
a good longterm strategy.
Number 22, most people are helpful.
Let them help.
Yeah, most people are helpful, but that
French girl who went to Norway, she
makes the point and it's very important.
You know, make sure you're
good before you get there.
So if you go to Norway and you
aren't very good in Norwegian.
As helpful as I am sure the Norwegians
are, they're going to speak to you in
English because they think they're being
helpful by speaking to you in English.
So you can't treat
random people as tutors.
You have to get yourself to a level where
people are comfortable speaking to you in
the language that you're trying to learn.
Number 23, there will be a lot of
ambiguity and miscommunication.
Yes, of course there will.
It comes with the territory, as I
mentioned earlier, that, uh, uncertainty
that's part of learning a language
and we shouldn't let it bother us.
24, these are the phases you go
through to learn a foreign language.
I mean, you can describe
the phases any way you want.
In my view, we have initial
success because from zero, suddenly
we understand a few things.
We're able to say a few things.
Then we go through a phase where we
feel we're not making any progress
whatsoever because there's so many
low frequency words that we need in
order to understand a movie, in order
to have meaningful conversations.
And then all of a sudden we turn
a corner and we have this feeling
of, wow, I'm somewhere, I'm B2.
And these phases may be different
for different people, but there is
a gradual process of working towards
success, however we define it.
And finally, he says, number
25, find a way to make it fun.
I would not put that as finally,
I would put that as upfront.
Figure out a way to enjoy the
process and at every stage.
And we talked about
stages, enjoy the process.
So I, for example, at an early stage,
uh, I find it enjoyable to listen to
our mini stories over and over again.
Comes a point where I can no
longer do that because we need
repetition, but we need new things.
And so I find it enjoyable to move
onto things that are difficult, where
I'm meeting some of the same words and
phrases, but in many different contexts,
and I'm learning about many things through
the language, and I find that enjoyable.
Obviously, when I have an opportunity to
use the language, if I'm in the country,
or if I hear someone speaking a language
that I've been learning, I'll immediately
pounce on them and speak to them.
And so that's also enjoyable.
So it's important at every stage
to find ways to enjoy the process,
not just finally, but even at the
very beginning, everyone has their
own approach to language learning.
If it works for them,
that's all that matters.
And I'm going to leave with you two
videos that I would suggest you have a
look at talking about the importance of
input, because I think that's crucial.
And that kind of underlies my
philosophy of language learning.
Thanks for listening.
Bye for now.